es un reconocimiento al trabajo de la
sociedad civil por los Derechos Humanos
este sábado desde oslo activistas de
velarus Ucrania y Rusia obtuvieron el
mayor reconocimiento por la defensa de
Derechos Humanos el Nobel de la paz
desde belarus el activista Alex
vialiatzky se llevó el premio aunque no
pudo recogerlo porque ya lleva un año y
medio en prisión por su trabajo social
por lo que su esposa Natalia pinchuk
acudió a por el galardón en su nombre
este premio pertenece a millones de
ciudadanos bielorrusos que se levantaron
y tomaron medidas en las calles y en
internet para defender sus derechos
civiles
entre las lágrimas de los asistentes y
premiados la guerra en Ucrania fue la
protagonista de la velada o Alexandra
más que recogió el galardón En nombre
del centro para las libertades civiles
de Ucrania arremetió de Rusia por
iniciar la guerra por sus ataques contra
civiles y se mostró en contra de
negociar la paz
para millones de personas las palabras
bombardeo tortura deportación o campos
de reclusión se han vuelto lugares
comunes
Esto no es una guerra entre dos estados
es una guerra entre dos sistemas
autoritarismo y democracia y democracia
el tercer premiado el ruso ya en
rachinski también atacó a Rusia
destacando su trabajo de investigación
sobre la represión en el país con la
organización Memorial la pregunta que
nos inquieta merecía realmente Memorial
el premio Nobel de paz hemos hecho mucho
y logrado más que poco pero evitó
nuestro trabajo la catástrofe el 24 de
febrero ahora los premiados se
repartirán los 917.000 euros del premio
en esta primera edición celebrada con
normalidad desde 2019 debido a la
pandemia de covid 19